I was an undergraduate at MIT in the mid
to late 60s there were very few
african-american students I really
wanted to make a difference and have MIT
be more hospitable to minority students
we created a summer program called
Project interphase which still operates
I was in the first project interphase
which took place in 1969 it was the
singular most important academic
experience I ever had in my life
interphase invites incoming freshmen to
spend the summer at MIT gain community
get to know the campus and also have a
taste of the coursework to get a jump on
a new semester if you do interphase you
hit the ground running it's not for the
credits that you get but for those
skills that you learn in those classes
especially study skills and office hours
oh geez office hours no one knew about
them coming in but officer is so
important it puts you ahead and I'll let
you know what you're going to see during
the semester and it really helped me in
that transition and to this day my
interface cohort are my closest friends
so they're the people I hang out with
the people I do homework with I study
with I recall that experience being
really instrumental in helping me to
feel a part of the MIT community we
invite departments labs and centers and
student facing organizations to come and
talk to the interfaces about all of
their resources how to get support from
student support services or how to go to
career advising and professional
development and work on a resume and
actually interview for job opportunities
and if they are interested in certain
majors we have department administrators
who are there to talk to them about
different disciplines and why these
majors might be exciting for them
interphase was a nice nest
and it's what I want to feel like for
the rest of my four years students who
come to MIT realize when they get here
that they themselves are you know very
talented but so is everyone else and
that introduces the need for them to
learn how to both give help and receive
help MIT is so much harder than you
think it is you have to learn to think
about the worlds in different ways think
about problems differently really figure
out how you learn how to ask for help
and that is something you just don't get
as a high schooler it's more than just
being invited to number one engineering
schools and having access to all these
professors but it's being taught how to
navigate it it's being comfortable in
your own skin it's feeling like you
actually belong here it's definitely a
community that you stick with it's not
just something that happens in the
summer and then you go off into your
classes and then you say hi in the
hallways it's a security net so that you
can feel comfortable the hemic it's
wonderful for me to be back here as a
faculty member and think about 28 years
ago first being introduced to the ome
and how profound an impact those
programs had on myself as an individual
as well as on my professional career I
don't know where I would be without
interphase thank God it to this program
you